this is the meet you this is the danger
bismillah al hamdulillah Salaam alaikum
peace be unto you how many your host you
are watching the Dean show this week is
kids week that's right we've had all the
adults on the show now we want to bring
you the future generations to come
parents doing a great job some parents
want to do a great job they don't know
how so that they need some motivation so
inshallah God willing when you see some
of these kids that we are interviewing
and you see some of the wonderful work
that they're doing you'll get inspired
and hopefully you will have a better
idea on how you can do a better job a
good job on educating your kids and
calling them to the goodness that the
creator of the heavens and earth calls
all of us too because you know that when
we die everything stays behind but that
righteous child the good deeds they
still keep coming in so when we come
back we're going to talk to zohair who's
also authored a book and has read over
1400 books I believe that's about 39
books somewhere around there a month
it's not too bad huh so when we come
back we're going to talk to him stay
tuned here on the dl this is the theme
the beach
this is the thing you know this is the
things is the teacher
this is the menu this is the days of
Athene jus this is the things
and we're back here on the Dean show
with Zafar so far is that your name yes
Salaam alaikum little brother how is it
how are you I'll handle it laughs now
what did you just say you said it
hamdulillah what does that mean I mean
all praise to God all praises to God
yeah that's wonderful tell us now you're
here on the Dean show have you ever
watched the Dean show before yes are you
ready to have some fun yes now you are
the brother we've had your sister on the
show what's her name her name is alia
Alia so she's older than you right right
now she's written more books are you
planning on catching up to her because
you're also an author of what how many
books have you authored 11 so how do you
author your mom helps you out with this
yes yeah what's the name of your book
the Dead all my book is things ricketts
in Elk strangers things every kid should
know strangers yes tell us a little bit
about your book at the beginning I had a
story and at the end has a few tips few
tips give us one of those tips there it
tells you um that they'll do who's a
stranger estrellas on who you don't know
so to stay away from strangers right
don't take candy from strangers yeah
anything don't get in a car with a
stranger things like that right right
that's a good book to write and how many
books have you read I read over fourteen
hundred books fourteen hundred books so
that's about let's say around close to
40 books a month that's good so your mom
told us that you cried there's a story
in the Quran you know the Quran now
that's my next question who is
Rasulullah shula's Muhammad peace be
upon him and who is Muhammad Muhammad is
well as
mrs. George sent from God so he's the
last messenger sent to mankind was he
just sent to the Muslims or he sent for
everybody Sanford everybody now in this
Quran there's a story about a prophet
named Yusuf do you know who Yusuf is yes
now we're not talking about Yusuf Estes
or use of Islam we're talking about use
of the Prophet your mom told us that
when you read this story you cried is
that true chu now all right why did you
cry because his brothers were really
mean to him and they three years of
peace be upon material cement father
yeah cool peace be upon him Brewery
seven grandchildren blind imagine how
would you feel if return until oh wow so
this was something very sad it made you
sad huh yeah tell us what are some of
the fun things that you like to do a lot
of the fun things I like to do is read I
see 1400 books that's a lot of reading
yeah now are you trying to catch up with
your sister she's read like how many
2200 books yes do I need to a hundred
you guys compete like have a good
competition you're trying to catch up to
her yeah yeah what do you inspire to be
what do you want to be when you grow up
I like to move the Quran and shall not
I'd like to have a risk organization or
gonna help people is taking cars they're
just water fire stuff like that wait so
the one thing you said you want to
memorize the verbatim word of God the
Quran which that's not hard to do
because that's one of the miracles of
the Quran that it's the last and final
Testament the last and final revelation
is memorized by millions of people all
over the world you want to be one of
those who also has memorized it yeah so
you're working have you memorized some
of it already yes I'm not sure exactly
it what's your what's one of the surahs
that you like to recite most often
I cosa can you recite it for us yes old
urban language a starting bismillah
hamano him and i doing I could go
through send it up big one huh in San
Rocco was up attached
you
you
you
do you know how to recite and fatty huh
yeah can you go ahead and recite this
for us this is the this is for our
audience this is the the opening chapter
to the verbatim word of God the Quran
being recited in its original how it was
revealed 1400 years ago this is how it's
being recited by a 20 year old how old
are you 6 year old I was joking ok by a
six-year-old go ahead take it away I
would be like him in the Shaitaan a
regime bismillahir rahmanir rahim
alhamdu lillahi rabbil enemy and a run
an array him Maliki imagine yeah can I
do I can stay in medina sir almost akin
SI raat 11am dilation waiting maha to be
L AM what a daunting and
I mean mashallah we'll be right back
with more hair on the Dean show when
outside everything looks good you see
the hundred-thousand-dollar cars you see
a lot of diamonds you see a lot of
females and they think that this is you
know this is a life this is this is like
you know paradise right here on earth
any one job to go into someone's heart
to change their heart your job is to
toki wartooth I am not afraid to stand
alone I am not afraid to stay back here
on the Dean show with my little brother
well in Islam we called each other
brothers because we're brothers in faith
so far eight years old and you are the
brother of hacia right alia I'm sorry
alia you are the brother of alia and
she's the author of many books you are
you've authored one book and before we
went to a break you recited some of the
quran surah what hundred relatable enemy
yes so tell us now you masha'Allah are
doing some good things do you have other
kids that you have from that our your
friends that you also play with and that
you also recycle on with and you learn
together with yes what do you guys like
do for fun you play soccer basketball
someone
the kid things normal kids like you like
to do like circle and stop circle like
circling a sec oh yeah so tell us now so
far what are your dreams and goals in
life my juice turmeric on Angela I would
like to have risked organization I can
help people who is ticking cars did just
water fire stuff like that so that's
what I asked you earlier so that was the
one thing before we went to break to
memorize the Quran what did you say
after that what did you want to do after
that say it again I like to have a
rescue organization a what organization
a rescue a rescue organization you want
to rescue people yeah oh I see and what
else so we got memorizing the verbatim
word of God the Quran a rescue
organization and what else I would like
to be a firefighter tell us do you know
about a lot of the profits you mentioned
Yusuf can you name some of the other
prophets of islam sure you Sofia cool
piece pop on him Sleiman and mohammed
asa musa noura hood what
you mean that's good what about Jesus
peace be upon him what do you when
someone asks you about Jesus what do you
tell him a non-muslim if he asks you
about Jesus I tell them Jesus is that is
it on the second messenger of god he's
one of the messengers of God yeah nice
and if people ask you who was a law what
do you tell him i told them that Allah
is our Creator and it creates everything
and it gives intelligent to people
there's a beautiful powerful surah in
the quran surah a class do you know the
Sura whoo hoo allah hoo ahad look can
you recite this Frost because this is a
great explanation of who Allah is all
the banana shaitana redeem bismillahir
rahmanir raheem who a long ride a lot of
summit well I'm and let me a new one and
I'm going to ask you another question
before we leave also tell us about
Abraham you know the story about Abraham
and the Quran can you tell us about this
story that once dirt was another
messenger named Abraham peace be upon
him and his father worshiped idols so
one day he decided to look for a lot so
he saw the start I said this is my lord
but now the star went away and it
believes that that a lot cannot go away
he could not be scared
so he saw the moon shine bright so I
believe that this is my lord but the
moon went away when I was day so she
everything said the moon of law cannot
go away so he saw the Sun and did he
said this is my lord and in the sun went
away and he said this a lot does not go
away then he realized that Allah wasn't
the moon star or sun he wasn't the moon
he wasn't the stars or the Sun he
created all these things that me so
should we worship the Sun should we
worship the moon should we worship the
stars should we worship Jesus should we
worship Mohammed or should we worship
the God the creator of all these things
what would you say I'd say that girls
are cleared of all of these things we
should worship the one who created Jesus
right right the God who created Mohammed
right the God who created the sun in the
moon and everything in this universe
yeah that's simple isn't it right good
job alright so you want to memorize the
Quran you recited two verses of the
crown for us is there any other one that
you like that you can recite for us yes
which one and that's what go ahead is
that yeah and that's all I was but I
aten NASA daha Luna feeding the F word
yeah it's a bit happy hun d-duh pickle a
sock fit and now we can it'll add that
good job good job so now when you get
older would you like to come back on the
Dean show yes inshallah ok so you keep
doing good you keep worshiping the One
God obeying your parents learning all
the different beautiful things that the
crater calls you to do and inshallah God
willing we'll have you back soon on the
Dean show to check up on your progress
and how you're doing how's that sound
yes please be with you Salaam alaikum
sly all right and that was little man
Zafar six years old already the author
with the help of his parents one book
and I hope that this encourages you to
get your children towards doing one of
the some of the most wonderful things
that the crater God Almighty and Eric we
say Allah he's called us to do he's
called us to worship Him alone he's
called us to implement Islam and he sent
down the Quran which is the last and
final revelation sent to mankind and as
you can see you got to hear some of the
verbatim word of God the Quran by the
young six-year-old he's inspiring to
memorize the Quran so I hope you're also
encouraging your children to memorize
the book of allah the book of the
creator of the heavens and earth which
was revealed over a span of 23 years we
have it today and its original unedited
unchanged untampered with this is a
revelation from the crater that have is
an earth which is millions memorized by
millions all over the world and you got
to hear a little bit of it from our
guest today and I hope that this is an
inspiration to all of you to continue if
you are ready if you're not to get on
the ball because as you know def is
approaching its close and you won't get
to take all those worldly things with
you the material things but the one of
the things that stays behind is a
righteous child so you'll never be at
loss if you're educating your children
the right way teaching them how to be
the best not only in acts of worship but
also best for being a benefit for
society and mankind doing good inviting
people to good and this is how when you
leave this life your good deeds are
still going to be cashing in there still
going to be coming in when you have a
righteous child and when you leave that
child is left behind doing righteousness
so with that said we hope to see you
again next time here on the Dean show
until then peace be unto you the dvds
for Dawa is allah has said in the Quran
in surah now 16 125 will do elasa be
laid up bookable hikmah to invite all to
the way of your lord with wisdom
beautiful preaching and reason with them
in ways that are best and this is a
great opportunity for you to take up the
obligation take up the call as allah has
told you to do and share this beautiful
message with the world islam submission
to the One God doesn't see what
everyone's talking about you find one
contradiction it can't be from God what
the rationale idea the rational
explanation is you do your best give up
for spring guidance I will never give up
spending this message hope there you
take that necessary step you don't know
if you're gonna live till tomorrow so
you got to find that urgency to do the
right thing right now if you say that
you're not believe in Jesus you have
stepped outside of this then you cannot
be a Muslim is attended our faith to
you
you